joining us at five i'm brian loftis and
i'm denise valdez well if you had to
fill up your tank in the past few days
or maybe over the weekend then you
definitely felt the pain at the pump
yeah gas prices are rapidly rising
here's what we're paying currently an
average of 461 per gallon that's for
regular gas and that's according to aaa
okay but that is a significant increase
from just a week ago remember this when
the cost was a little bit more than just
four dollars let's say hovering here at
402 but then look at this an even bigger
jump from a year ago when the average
cost was sitting at just three dollars
and 11 cents so with the rising prices
many who rely on gas for work like uber
or lyft or taxi drivers they're being
forced to adjust sally jeremiah on this
story speaking of drivers today joining
us live now from an uber parking area
right near unlv with their concerns
sally
as you guys can see right behind me
several rideshare vehicles waiting to
pick up passengers from the airport and
they are also hoping that customer ride
destination is convenient to help save
on fuel costs
[Music]
for those making a living transporting
people the cost is hitting them hard an
uber driver who doesn't want to be
identified says the gas going up each
day is concerning his suv requires
premium gas and that's already up to
five dollars a gallon he adds at this
point he can only keep doing this for so
many hours a day because filling up his
tank is something he can't afford
anymore currently this is his only
source of income refuse a trip that was
a 125 minutes which is like two hours i
had to refuse that trip because if i
took that trip first of all i would only
get 50 percent of that and then secondly
if it was a two hour trip then that
would be two hours in one direction and
then with a fair and then two hours back
empty the uber driver has been driving
for two years and needs to work 12 or
more hours a day seven days a week just
to break even
back out live that driver tells me he's
currently spending about 60 to 80
dollars
a day and if gas prices continue to go
up he's going to have to look for
another job for now reporting live sally
jaramillo live local now